[Music]
in our morning rounds were marking
breast cancer awareness month with a
brand new survey on women with the
disease one in eight women will be
diagnosed with breast cancer in her
lifetime the American Cancer Society
found deaths for women from breast
cancer continued to decline but at a
slower rate than previous years more
than 3.8 million women living in the
United States have a history of breast
cancer CBS News medical contributor
that's dr. David agus is a leading
cancer specialist he joins us to sort
out all the numbers always good to have
you here Thank You Gayle there's not a
woman I know that gets a mammogram that
when she goes in that doesn't say to
herself before is today the day myself
included so I think there's good news
and bad news and that the number of
deaths from breast cancer are going down
but the number of women who are getting
breast cancer is going up why is that
well first of all 40 percent decrease
over the last three decades in breast
cancer that's great news the problem is
women are still dying of this horrible
disease and one in eight women will get
it you know we as a nation or getting
larger and we're having fewer children
both of which why does that affect your
breast cancer so being large or obese
increases the rate of breast cancer as
does not having children increases the
rate of breast cancer having children
later increases the rate also why
actually reason no levels are different
because of both of them and it's somehow
the hormonal milieu of us want portends
for more breast cancer and one portents
for Less so these are important
observations and obviously as our norms
in the country change we're seeing that
increase we're getting a little bit
better at treating it though and that's
why the death rate is going down so what
role did the treatment options play as
to whether you survived breast cancer so
first it's diagnosed udderly that's the
most important thing film it's not art
no question about it but our treatments
today have changed dramatically over the
last decade we now have the ability to
target molecules or on switches within
the breast cancer and also I think
really importantly we can block the
don't eat me signal on the cancer
allowing your own immune system to
attack the cancer so chemotherapy has
gotten better together with molecular
targeted therapy and immunotherapy there
is real hope for actually continuing to
lower the death rate you know
when Angelina Jolie did the rocker gene
testing that was about five six years
ago a lot of women followed suit and
said I'm going to do that too based on
Hurley which at the time you said was a
really good idea how is genetic testing
changed since then
you know when she announced it in the
New York Times in a piece I wrote a
companion piece and what I wrote about
is that it was predatory practice some
monopolistic because it was thousands of
dollars a ransom a woman had to pay to
look at her own DNA she literally had to
pay five thousand dollars to look and
see if she had this gene or not well now
that test is commonplace in less than a
hundred dollars because the US Supreme
Court said you can no longer patent a
gene in our country so the test has been
democratized and every woman has a right
to know what's inside our DNA but do you
recommend that you get the test because
the price has gone down no question
about it
I mean to me knowledge is power man or
woman should have this test and you
should know if you're at risk for this
breast cancer ovarian cancer other
cancers associated with these genes and
also whether your children or parents
are at risk knowledge to me is really
key to knowing what to do why are black
women more susceptible to higher rates
of breast cancer it's a great question
and obviously the death rate seven two
to one and the death rate is
significantly higher in black women so
breast cancer death rate correlates to
being obese and there's a larger body
messing this in general in black women
and in addition the biology may be
different as well as access to care the
interesting thing is in the state of
Massachusetts where there's care for
everybody the death rates are similar
between white women and black women so I
think there's a lesson there is that we
have to increase access to care so we
all get these remarkable advances that
have happened in the treatment of breast
cancer
thank you dr. David agus oh it's good to
have him here